hello everyone thanks for coming so yeah
so today we're going to talk about cloud
on parentis I think you've been hearing
about cloud run and cloud room for
anthos throughout today and you know we
came here talked about building
platforms and higher level abstractions
then she really came here talking about
until service nice so we're gonna try to
piece these put these pieces together
and let's see if we can build something
higher platform so my name is ahmed al
Park and I'm a developer advocate I'm
joined by Jay here from our San
Francisco office he's a customer
engineer and we'll be talking about
kelabra and chlidren and toast lay so as
you've seen earlier today yeah when you
get into the Antos world there are all
these abstractions and components that
you'd like to build a full-fledged
infrastructure that you can freely
deploy applications but we think of
higher level abstractions for example
your developers I bet they don't want to
learn kubernetes most of the developers
ideally should not be learning
kubernetes right that's why we want to
build platforms we want to build these
sort of higher level abstractions so why
don't we go so it seems like piece of
the puzzle is missing out there and this
is precisely what cloud run on entosis
but again pretty much any developer
abstraction we built for example in this
case
Quadron entos it's not the end game it
takes you to some level but maybe there
is something else that you can put on
top of it and we're gonna talk about
that too
so this by no means is the end game in
terms of the very experience so let's
talk about service I know you didn't
come here to hear about service did you
so you might think you know a I you know
I have on Prem stuff maybe you know I
want to do multi cloud stuff why are you
telling you about service and reason for
that is serverless world has been you
know taking the internet by the storm
because they have done something that is
pretty remarkable I can write my
application code and I can directly
deploy it without knowing anything about
the infrastructure whatsoever
right so this might be totally
irrelevant to you if you heard about you
know Google cloud functions lambda and
these sort of things these are
technologies maybe this is very
different than what you've been already
doing but there is a there's something
that we can learn from and the fact that
you're developers do not
about the infrastructure anymore and
they can be productive they can write
code and go to production in a very
short amount of time I think that's
pretty remarkable so when we think about
serverless
we're seeing that you know there's an
operational model that makes serverless
serverless and there's a programming
model it's first of all there is no
inframan Ajmer you know in the service
world they have this place they don't
touch machines anymore they don't
configure load balancers firewalls and
you know just because the infrastructure
under them updates regularly and it's
patch regularly they just write their
code and everything else their
dependencies and the OS packages and the
runtimes everything that gets patched
quite a clog provider so there's a word
like that out there and they pay per use
for example you get one request you pay
for one request that's it and similarly
they've been constructing their
applications as little micro services or
little functions lambdas and these
applications are invoked with events or
requests that come to that application
so they've been writing these services
and you know I'm assuming so you also
have services that sound like that so at
the end I think we can learn something
from this so server lists at the end of
the day is nothing more than efficient
developers and efficient operators this
is what it's bringing you know
developers to these sort of platforms if
you look at it like Google App Engine
was released a decade ago that that's
not me I mean we've been doing service
for a pretty long time and the reason
people have been opting in for that
model is they're pretty efficient at it
they can write their code go to the
production or staging in a minute or so
and this is precisely why I think there
is something to learn from that right so
duper's care about velocity right they
wanted air you write their code they
want to take their code and put it into
production and they want to do it it do
it in a reliable way they want when they
achieve their code they don't want to
hear from their you know operators or in
a DevOps person or they say sorry that
they broke everything so they want that
reproducibility they want that
monitoring they want you know these
pieces that makes the whole thing
reliable so this is where we introduced
the cloud run so cloud run as of last
week it's a general available product
it's Google's service platform that lets
you run any container image in Google's
fully managing for us track
give us a container of it let's say
there's a webserver in that image and
that's the end of the story we run that
image for you we give you an endpoint
that is fully secured we scale it for
you
you call Google you say I'm gonna have a
Black Friday sales coming up tomorrow or
in a week or so
can you you know schedule me can you
like allocate something like this to me
the others like maybe I want 5,000
containers and then Google tells you
okay you're good to go
and then next thing you know Black
Friday 9 a.m. you're getting hundreds of
thousands of requests and Quadron can
effectively scale that for you and we're
gonna talk about how that looks like so
as I talked earlier plot run you come
with a container image that you're
already familiar with that's the price
of entry as long as you can package your
application into a cloud into a
container you can deploy it to cloud run
and you can run any language and
framework so this is the this is how it
differs and most other service platforms
because normally when we think of
functions and like appengine sort of
paradigms we've restricted to certain
languages and like their versions right
normally you can write Python 2.7 and
3.2 or something but you can't go beyond
that so cloud run gives you that
flexibility and it's fully managed
infrastructure and you pay for you know
what you use and you get rapid auto
scaling that effectively handles the
traffic spikes so you know you're still
probably thinking this is you know
irrelevant to me this is not quite what
I do but anyway I'm going to show you
how cloud run looks like in action can
we switch to the demo machine please
alright alright so this is Google Cloud
console you're probably familiar with
that already today so this is the club
right here I then I say create a service
the only thing that I'm asked about is
what is your container image so I I'm
gonna type an image here I'm gonna talk
about this image in a bit actually so
let's actually go to the repository so I
have a repository here publicly
available on github
you know I'm Brendan we're gonna deploy
some software from Gap this service
claims to be converting word documents
to PDF ok let's see how it does it I see
a doctor file here who I guess I'm gonna
build a container with that so if I go
to that Python image Python source
product source code I'm gonna see that
down here this program is actually
nothing more than something that pulls
in too liberal of this if you're not
familiar that's the OpenOffice right so
this is sort of what we call the legacy
software right there is like 15 year old
program that I can run in a container so
I can accept requests I get a word file
and then I give it to OpenOffice I get a
PDF output and I send it back as a
response to the request so this is what
the application looks like I already
built it and built a docker file so I'm
gonna directly to put I can't wait to do
Clara it asks me where do you want to
deploy I want to say let's deploy on
cloud wrongfully managed person and then
I say allow every single request without
authenticating people because I want to
build a public application right ok so
what's happening right now is Google
Cloud is taking my application image
from Google container registry and it's
going to deploy it on a fully managed
platform and it's going to give me a URL
back so that URL is going to be fully
secured with HTTP I can do I am and like
access controls and stuff like that if I
want to so in a few seconds here
hopefully the service is going to come
up and we're gonna see that the
application is running completely
managed so at that point I can give that
URL so you know anyone I can run it TV
ad with that because I'm not managing
any infrastructure anymore like I'm not
in the business of managing anything
regarding the operations of this
application so here I get this
application you know I click to it
there's a bit of a cold start because
it's the first time I deploy the
application so it's coming up but
essentially you know it's running this
application which is a you know PDF
Converter I think I'm running into
Internet
here anyway we're gonna come back to
that later me yeah that doesn't seem to
be loading right now I think this is
your conference Wi-Fi failing us okay
let's go back to the slide now we're
gonna come back to that later all right
can we go back to the slides please
slides please slightly can see you know
what
until the slides come up I'm gonna click
on this once more no that's okay I think
the Wi-Fi is failing me pretty well
right now
all right let's go back to the slides
please all right yeah so essentially
what I just did there is I deployed a
legacy application because I was able to
put it in a container
right and then I was able to give it to
Google so that it can run it in a fully
managed environment that is with
Reparata scaling and scale to zero and
then at the end I got this HTTP endpoint
that was fully managed by Google so what
if you want these functionality in your
kubernetes cluster so this is precisely
where cloud run on anthos comes into
picture so we want to give you the
choice of where you want to have a store
experience because it will per you know
I can just pull the Container image and
go through lots of pretty well manage
the environment that already does a lot
of simplifies a lot of the operations
for me right so this is what cloud for
Antos comes into the picture it's the
same experience that you get on a
service platform it runs in your GK
kubernetes cluster next to your
kubernetes workloads so this is still
kubernetes you're still running a
kubernetes cluster but you give your
developers a higher level abstraction
and if you want to customize all the
auto scaling and how does the log
balancing work you know this is pretty
customizable and I'm gonna touch on that
shortly so you know your developers
might be you know maybe they want a UI
so you know this is what I did I
the UI I could use the CLI as well if
you're into infrastructure is code for
example in the previous talk you've seen
Vic and his friends demo a an
application that is purely deployed from
a Yama file so if I want that I can
still go that route I can write a handle
file and I can deploy that and under the
covers the way clouds run and clutter on
anthos work the same way is because they
both use this thing called K native API
and K native is that open technology
that let makes this possible to run your
applications either on Google's fully
managed platform or in your clusters
either on cloud or on pram or maybe up
another cloud provider so Canada is a
total source API and the implementation
that codifies these practices of running
micro services or service applications
on kubernetes it's an open API it is
jointly developed by Google Red Hat IBM
and few others so by adding creative
which is in this case managed by cloud
run on an close to my cluster I'm able
to run stateless applications more
effectively I can go somewhere I can
click a button and then that application
is pretty much managed and auto scaled
for me at that point like I don't have
to worry about you know configuring
horizontal part of the scalars memory
based scaling and these sort of things
anymore
so in terms of auto scaling if you look
at kubernetes so that you're probably
writing all these like horizontal part
of the scalar configurations that are
memory and CPU bays so actually
something needs to happen like for
example if your CPU utilization needs to
hit 7080 percent and then at that point
you're going to get auto scaling happen
right but by then it might be too late
so in cater case we're doing rapidly
request based auto scaling
anytime a request comes that's an input
to the auto scaling machine so if I get
suddenly hundred requests and I can't
handle hundred requests that actually
means that I need to hold on to those
requests and add more pods so that I can
tend the traffic to and another thing is
scaled to zero maybe you don't care
about this but actually if your
application is not running this gives
you a greater ability to put fit more
applications into one cluster if an
application does not get any requests
it's not running next time it gets gets
the request we wake up the application
but at the same time
hold on to that request we don't drop
the request so this is not available in
Korea neighs and this is what you get
with Canada and similarly normally in
communities you have the connection base
like TCP base out of load-balancing
right I'm sure if you're using this in
production you probably realize that's
not the best way to do a lot balancing
and in creative case we do per request
load balancing and traffic splitting so
this lets you do cannery rollouts or
Bluegreen deployments right and this is
all possible because in an endless
cluster there is an foe service mesh
providing what providing work balancing
capabilities and then stack driver
support that lets you monitor your
applications so now we're going to go
back to the demo machine again and let's
try the cloud run on Antos and how
different could it actually be all right
so I think I'm going to turn off my
Wi-Fi I'm hoping I'm connected over the
wire right now let's try this all right
it was a previous application that I was
trying to connect to I don't know why
it's still not working but let's go
ahead and deploy the same application in
a cloud Rama man on an ant rose cluster
this time so I go here and I type the
image name again yep and then this time
I'm gonna say let's choose a cloud run
Antos cluster and in my project it turns
out there's a GK cluster available I
choose that and then I say let anyone
connect to this application then I go
ahead and create the application so
again the same thing I use the same
developer experience as a developer this
is what I see I have an application I
have maybe like a memory CPU setting but
at the end of the day I just want to
deploy it and in a few seconds I get a
URL back I click on it so this was the
application that you were supposed to
see in the first place
you know as you can see here I'm able to
deploy the same application to cloud run
on anthos but I told you earlier this is
still kubernetes right so let's go ahead
and take a look at that so here I'm
going to bring up my cloud shell if you
don't know that that's a pretty cool
feature we have so so let's take a look
at my kubernetes cluster let's take
let's try to understand what's going on
here
and as you can see I'm a tree No
gk cluster here and what i just deployed
was actually a kubernetes object so if I
for example if I close this down here if
I look at the mo this looks a lot like
kubernetes right this is you know all
these specs and containers resources
memory limits okay so now let's try to
actually make sense of this so here I'm
going to ask for a serve
that's for an API type called usually
I'll get K service so K service is the K
native service abstraction it's not
quickly named because there's already a
coronated service object but hold on for
a moment alright so it seems like I
already have the PDF application I
deployed in the cluster running right so
I see the service here if I do the QCD
I'll get SVC which is the normal
kubernetes service I can see that
there's already a service created for
that PDF application here and
essentially it's making the application
that I just deployed available within my
cluster so if someone else wants to call
this application within the same cluster
they can do that maybe I can limit
connectivity to only cluster I can say
don't allow anyone externally pulling
this application I can have a completely
private micro service deploy this way
right so for example let's let's take a
look at the pods what's running in this
cluster so you're gonna see that there
is a pod running but it's actually going
away its terminating and the reason it's
terminating is because I didn't send it
any requests for the past 30 seconds or
so right so if I go back and refresh so
the right now a new container is coming
up it came up and it served the
application so if I go back and run cube
CT I'll get pods again as you can see
here there's any pod running and those
there's just started like 8 seconds ago
right so this is sort of how can a door
works alright let's go back to the slide
please
can we go back to the slides please all
right so this is cloud ruminant us in a
nutshell right so what I just did was
you know I had the same dual prayer
experience I went from the UI which just
told me hey choose your container image
I specify my container image just like
I'm doing surrealist stuff but I was
able to get this in my crib in a deist
cluster so we so how can it works under
the covers it's still kubernetes objects
your developer of your DevOps people and
your administrators and operations
people can go and configure these
objects further you can impose
kubernetes policies on them you can use
anthos config management to spread these
objects or apply policies that would
limit access to these objects right so
because this is still kubernetes and i
won't actually go back to the demo
machine momentarily because i forgot to
show the traffic splitting so let's
actually see that too you know I just
deployed this another application here
it is called hello app right so this is
running a similar similar application
image if I click on that that's gonna
come up shortly you know as you can see
this is a hello world 1.0 you know as a
developer I can say hey deploy a new
provision for example I get 2.0 and then
I say let's go ahead and deploy this and
while deploying or after I deploy this
application I can actually say let's
manage the traffic for example I want I
want to sound 50% of the traffic to v2
so I go ahead and say this you know
again this is possible because we're
using ANFO service mesh under the covers
we get that load balancer with is do we
get the same would be balancing
capabilities that you would normally get
in an anthos cluster right so I go back
to the application now every time i
refresh i'm either gonna get v1 or v2
right so refreshing 1 1 1 2 so that's
pretty much how traffic splitting works
if I were to set this to a value like 5
or 10% I will be able to do cannery
rollout or blueberry in deployments so
this is pretty much how traffic
splitting works in a nutshell let's go
back to the slides please yeah and
finally this is the kubernetes like
we're not adding new complexity this is
a software based stack I did load
balancing with some
where I deployed any application
configured in any application with
software
I didn't involve any sort of hardware in
this right I was able to use what's
already in your cluster which is the
Anto service mesh setup if I want to get
metrics out of this application this is
still possible
so now let's briefly talk about miry
migrating your applications to Quadra so
what sort of applications actually fit
into cloud round right so first of all
your application needs to be stateless a
lot of services are turns out stateless
yes there are stateful services as well
but if you have micro services front
ends you know anything that handles
events will processing queues these are
applications actually you know they're
fault-tolerant you can kill them or you
can scale them up and they usually pick
up the load and they continue where they
left off or something like that that
helps you build the applications that
are resilient so if you have an
application you can make it work on an
HTTP or gr PC port you can run it on
cloud run and ideally if it's not an
application that takes ten minutes to
start as you see here every time I get
any requests I start a new instance of
that and that instance stays away it
stays around so that I can send more
requests to it right but additionally
you can configure the que native
autoscaler I can go and say hey you know
what
I don't want cold starts so that's one
that's the biggest problem it's
serverless right people say there's cold
starts I want I don't want cold start in
that case you can say please scare my
application to maybe minimum one instead
of going to zero you can say I don't
want zero I want to keep it one so you
can have that on cloud run so here I
have the usual kubernetes deployment and
service file you know they're you know
they say hey I have this application
here's the image here's the CPU
requirements and then to make this
application accessible internally my
cluster I define a service so let's go
through this and see if there are like
commonalities that we can read out for
example replicas one I don't need
replicas one because with cloud Runner
anthos I'm getting out of scaling out of
the box I don't need to worry about how
many replicas are running are running
right and there are all these labels I
don't know if anyone here actually goes
and configures like labels on their
deployments so they can choose them and
have
overlapping labels and stuff like that
so that doesn't happen very often and
similarly on the service side there are
all these labels and I'm you know trying
to do the selector because I need to go
back to the deployment and match to the
pods deployable deployment and you know
I'm still in the business of doing port
numbers this is pretty interesting like
with quadrant on Antos you don't have to
do port numbers anymore
the port number is given to you and you
can customize that so there's that so
why don't we get rid of the service
object altogether and take the good
parts of the deployment so that gives us
the new Kei native service object as you
can see here it's pretty brief it only
has a few lines I can just specify my
deployment spec which contains the only
critical information about my container
what is my image what are my resources
if you need to add labels you can still
go and do that but you don't have to so
compared to the deployment object I
think we've come a long way like as you
can see pretty much what I just changed
was I change the API group and I took
the parts that mattered into the new
object and now I'm actually running on a
native who's Clara mementos so here I'm
gonna transport AJ and he's gonna talk
about eventing which is a critical part
in service developer experience right
thank you I want to create a data-driven
organization has anybody heard that
before maybe in the field may be their
manager has said that at some point time
who here has heard something about
data-driven organizations alright does
that actually mean anything like it's it
really it sounds like one of those terms
oh we're data-driven we collect a lot of
data we like data well what are we doing
with the data are we just storing it in
some warehouse and the Nevada desert is
it actually be is it actually being used
for something my theory is that when
people say they want a data-driven
organization what they actually mean if
they want an event-driven organization
they don't want to just to get arbitrary
data coming into their application they
actually want to know
that something is happening out there in
the world that their application needs
to respond to maybe you have a ride
share app and somebody has just ordered
a ride or maybe there's a traffic and
you want to be able to update the
estimated time of arrival you want to do
this data needs to serve a purpose so
when we start framing data as events
then it starts to serve a better purpose
for our applications someone we can
actually build a solution towards and in
fact if you saw one of the earlier
slides and we were talking about server
lists one of the six I guess you could
say segments of server list was
event-driven and how do we do that well
K native actually has a component called
a venting so cloud run is based on K
native serving K nabo venting is another
component that makes up this whole K
native suite if you will a venting is
well it's it allows you to declaratively
bind between event producers and
deployed services so now you're able to
just create a producer or a source that
creates the events that collects the
events and then just deploy services
that Reid said source you can scale from
a few events maybe you do update on your
inventory at the end of the day or maybe
you want to do a live stream and they
even create custom event pipelines to
connect with your own existing systems
so perhaps you have some kind of Kafka
cluster out there something we're gonna
talk about very soon so Kay native
eventing allows you to do all this this
is actually pretty important because you
might be saying well what happens in
that earlier that earlier set up when we
deployed I mean it gave us the URL why
don't I just you know kind of turn on
the fire hose and send all of my data to
that endpoint I mean that'll work right
I mean maybe you can actually do a lot
of things with K native venting here you
have a source which can be you know your
container it could be a github may be
something changed in github it could
your Kafka cluster it could be something
in kubernetes itself and it can just go
ahead and deploy to your service which
is fine but what happens when you want
to fan out what happens when you want
certain services to go to receive
certain events what if you want to
define events can't really do that as
easily when you're just doing the
straight HTTP and of course how do you
guarantee the events are sent if you're
doing it that way
so what can a de veau all you to do is
do a more complex or key native eventing
rather will allow you to do a more
complex serving of your events rather
than just turning on firehose so to
speak on two HTTP HTTP HTTP endpoint an
easier way to look at it and what I'm
going to be showing you is we have this
Kafka cluster out here we have K native
source K native source that is
essentially think of it as kind of a
bucket if you will where all the events
go to and that serves as the source of
all truth for the events that come in
then a broker is kind of a another
abstraction layer that you can then push
the events of the app so the source just
collects the add information broker kind
of gives a little more intelligent than
the app or service is what actually
functions there and it uses the event to
do whatever simple idea in terms of the
real world is you know we have our user
here they have a mobile phone they want
to order a pizza
with app we use confluent cloud and
confluent is actually founded by the
creators of Kafka and they actually have
a fully managed solution that you can
host on GCP to so you get open source
Kafka all the benefits of open source
Kafka plus an SLA and support so if
you're an enterprise wouldn't it be nice
to have somebody else worry about your
Kafka versus your developers and of
course while we're talking about that
you have the K native so let's go ahead
and look at our demo I actually recorded
it because I wish I had the confidence
to ally
but you know Internet up Wi-Fi is what
it is but hey uh hotel Wi-Fi before we
start playing the video just going to
explain a little bit about what you will
see I created a up there it is but it's
small anyway so what you will see is I
created a small little app all it does
is it pings Alpha Vantage alpha Vantage
get is API tool that essentially will
give you different financial data so
stock markets currency exchange all that
you get like five hundred free calls a
day so hey it's perfect if you're doing
a demo it will check and then it will
send the results to to kafka cluster and
then we will show you Mike a native
eventing can we restart that real quick
so then we'll wish I could stop myself
from clicking so I'm in the Kafka
cluster I'm in my cape kubernetes
cluster rather this all has key native
eventing and cloud run installed here's
my service
look there's cloud run there's currency
app that's the application I deployed on
cloud run alright now we're looking up
there's the API there's what the URL is
that's my cluster I showed you earlier
[Music]
so I'm gonna go ahead and take that URL
and go to go to postman and start
sending some API calls now this is my
endpoint basically it takes two
currencies USD and Japanese yen now
because of hotel Wi-Fi when I was
recording it this took a little while
well what it's going to be doing is it's
going to be comparing and giving you the
exchange rate it will show you what the
exchange rate is there there you go so
remember that number now we're gonna go
to you we're going to go and this is
actually consuming my Kafka cluster so
it Kafka got that number now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go ahead and get
all the pods that are running in that
namespace that I created event display
is kind of a bucket if you will or that
displays all the law
dogs that have been sent to the broker
we're gonna go ahead and look at the log
so cutesy tail we're gonna go ahead and
look at those logs and see what we can
find
now this is using a format called cloud
events which is an open source CN CF
built I guess format that for sending
event so we're keeping everything open
source it stores the data in base64 so
let's go in decode it and hey look at
that it matches so in pretty much real
time I was able to send that event to my
kubernetes cluster so let's go ahead and
wrap this up why cloud one on anthos
well easier deployment and operations
for micro services I read a study I
can't remember where but it said lie
around twenty five thirty percent of all
the of your developers time is actually
use doing non developer work so you know
he we hear the term full stack developer
a lot so that usually means I'm going to
have to write yam all I'm going to have
to manage nodes I'm gonna have to set up
databases we make it easier for you to
use micro services by abstracting away a
lot of that operator work for the
developers to deploy and then also make
it easier for the operators to work on
the stuff they need to work on and not
necessarily need to be a part of the
deployment process when an application
version needs to be deployed because of
that you have increased productivity
velocity hate those developers get that
twenty five thirty percent of their time
back to actually develop applications
and of course by then stories that it
enables your developers and operators to
be more successful and focus on the
things that matter and thank you and
here's how you get cloud run and all of
our code is in these repos and get some
tips and yeah
thank you for the time
you
you